and up on the mound today for manager
scott service and his young lefty
justice sheffield
sucks this high and deep out to right
dylan moore
back pedaling on it a couple of fly ball
outs to begin the ball game blackman's
six for eight in this series plus two
watts
and charlie swats his smaller right
and he's gonna have a
double it's really quite ridiculous
isn't it
i've never seen you you see guys get hot
he now has a 13-game hitting streak you
see guys get hot huey but rarely do you
see guys get charlie blackmon hot sound
man in scoring position for matt kemp
one two from sheffield
ties him up cut out and missed and
sheffield strands blackman at third
ederman on the hill with this two-in-one
record of 189 era 23 strikeouts to just
five walks
well jp crawford with the mariners first
hit of the ball game getting it out of
the way early in this one today
so one aboard right away no score
that'll bring up right fielder dylan
moore
crack deep out to right field blackman
having a chase after blackman looking up
and this is gone for a home run
number three on the season for dylan
moore and right away the mariners get on
the board
dylan moore we've talked about him
having some pop in his that this is the
second opposite field home run for him
this year his third overall exit v low
of 102. 371 feet
mariner is off to a fast start against a
very good pitcher builder david dole
leading off the top half of the second
swing enemies by dahl for strike three
so strikeout number two for justice
sheffield
this stays just fair seeger thrown from
cement long throw on a skip on to evan
white
nice play by the goal glover on the hot
corner two away
there's trevor story the hold by
sheffield runner breaks here's a pitch
swung on off the fist up the middle d
gordon on the slide on the shortstop
side of the bag nice dig again by evan
white we're going to be saying that for
years
dee got rid of it quickly it was a
one-hopper evan he got it like it was
nothing mariners take a two-nothing lead
to the top of the fourth the one-two
cut on and missed man that slider has
been filthy all afternoon
i've seen it at 78.79 this is a little
bit harder 83 miles an hour and just
buries it one on and one away and
that'll bring up centerfielder david
dahl the left-handers pitch swing and a
line drive over the shortstop and into
left center field lewis will come over
to field it blackman
will get over to third base and the
rockies have runners at the corners
great at bat by david dahl runners at
the corners and here's ryan mcmahon
there you go got him that time sheffield
a pump of the fist strike down number
five and he strands runners on the
corners he's facing story blackman and
kemp
here in the sixth inning the 2-2
he got him
how about a little bit of heat blowing
in story is strikeout victim number six
here's matt kemp two strikeouts
how about that on the outside corner
slider finishes kim
seventh strikeout for sheffield who's
matched a career best six innings
justice sheffield pitched a whale of a
sixth inning game here today striking
out seven didn't walk anybody that'll
bring up kyle seeger
first pitch hit the other way third
baseman owings grabs stumbles bobbles
everybody safe throws wide wild to first
that will get seeger to second louis the
third couple of strikeouts for evan
weinington
there you go a drive out to center field
dahl on the track
the ballpark holds it but kyle lewis
tags
productive plate appearance there for
young avenue tim lopes to step in
the opposite way and through tim lopes
makes it four nothing mariners kyle
seeger scoring from third
two outs for dither
and a right field blackman charging
playing on a bounce lopes with good
speed coming home blackman's throw is up
the line lope scores dee to second and
he is safe
making five nothing mariners
here's story trevor is all for three
that is sharply hit into center field to
base it and the rockies are on the board
as hampson comes around
on story's ninth rbi
matt kemp had a tough day against
justice sheffield
and this ball is lying to left field
that'll help
around third is story he'll score
stopping at second
is charlie five to two here come the
rockies taylor williams takes over for
the marines this will be his seventh
appearance
and dahl lines this into right field for
a base hit blackman around third charlie
will score
five to three
and up comes daniel murphy one of the
leading hitters in the national league
here's the one-two
cut on and missed
95 mile an hour fastball taylor williams
gets the maritals out of a jam 2-1 for
the mariners for third baseman kyle
seeger
and the 3-2 to seeger and it's down low
for ball four and the mariners have the
bases loaded here in the bottom of the
eighth two down
and here is first baseman evan white
and this
should get
kindly out of it wow you talk about
dancing
with fire
taylor williams continuing on
pops him up
lopes
has his eyes on it and left
and the ball game is over the mariners
win it they salvage the series they take
down the rockies five to three